so we have breaking news the phillies
will not start vince velasquez for
tonight's ball game david hale will make
the start so this is what happened this
was about a half hour ago vince was
holding his forearm squeezing his
forehead forearm with dave lundqvist the
phillies bullpen coach paul buchheit the
phillies athletic trainer came out and
it looked like they were looking at his
index finger as it turns out vince has
numbness in that index finger so they've
decided to scratch him for tonight's
ball game and then moments after that
david hale came running out of the
clubhouse and he will make the spot
start tonight david hale warming up out
on the mound the unexpected spot start
for him tonight hale's numbers this year
this will be his 12th game first start
5.09 era aguilar the 1-1 ground ball the
shortstop that should be two there's one
and brad miller easily able to spin it
at second base six four three two outs
lovely you know the thing about aguarr
is that he'll hit it to double plays a
because everybody does but b hits the
ball so hard that if he gets it on the
ground to an infielder it's an easy one
he's not the fleet of the foot either
dickerson the batter
swinging to miss the strength there
that's first and foremost yep is to
throw a force seamer to get dickerson
and the side is retired nice start for
david howe sandy alcantara back to work
it's his 10th start sandy looking for a
big time bounce back here tonight after
the worst start of his big league career
in la friday night mccutcheon last night
hit a home run went one for three
and sandy
gets the strikeout of mccutcheon his
first of the night went away i'll tell
you what partner i i wouldn't want to be
facing sandy tonight knowing his
mentality and
having watched him for the last few
seasons what drives this young man one
and two on hoskins swinging a miss and
that'll do it a couple of strikeouts in
the inning so a good beginning here for
alcantara he strikes out a pair and
strands the harper walk we're through
one tonight at citizens bank park rojas
the 1-0 pitch swung on and belted high
and deep left field you can forget about
this one long gone miguel rojas with his
third home run of the season and rojas
who has both hits against david hale
tonight let's put the marlins on top one
to nothing with a big big swing a no
doubter to left for miggy row so it's
actually zach wheeler who's gonna take
the bat right here quick and miss and
sandy's got five strikeouts the first
time through the order here's andrew
mccutchen there's a swing and a miss he
tied him up with a change up now the
strikeout make it six for sandy two way
in the third three consecutive
strikeouts back to last inning
three on the changeup garrett cooper
dickerson over at first a line out to
right field first inning for coop
garrett cooper
down the left field line this one hit a
ton into the second deck for coupe
two-run shot and the marlins extend it
to a three-nothing lead now great swing
of the bat from coop sped up the swing
just a little bit matt moore got ahead
with a couple of fastballs got them by
coupe and then went to the breaking ball
and coupe visited the second deck hello
mr cooper reese hoskins lead things off
for the phillies on o2 a swing and a
miss he ran that one in and he's got
another k nice little backed up slider
right there that ends up swinging over
but again you look at the board and you
you think man he's got a lot of zeros up
there but 64 pitches and he just started
the fourth you would think nah there's
no way because
you know he's had to work but glenn they
really not have not been squaring him up
at all i mean it's just foul ball foul
ball foul ball sandy ready to do it
again coming to nap
and the swing of the miss dials up 99.
so for a fourth straight inning two
strikeouts for sandia contra he's
whipped eight in the first four tonight
corey dickerson has struck out walked
and scored a run tonight
dickerson left center field going to get
down herrera tries to cut it off just
kind of knocks it down and dickerson
into second
with a double so dickerson to strike out
his first time but a walk in a run
scored now a double here in the sixth
now here's cooper in the sixth
cooper lifts one right field down the
line long run for harper that one falls
in fair
rattles around in the corner dickerson
is going to score
cooper is on his way to third and he'll
make it yeah koopa loop have a night
there might be a little extra space in
that right field corner tonight
chased it all the way to the line
did not come up with it which gave hoop
an opportunity to stretch a double into
well i think coop's okay with this a
rare triple for the big guy
ball one strike to count the
right-handers 1-1 pits wallet ground
ball right side miller has it to first
an rbi ground out as cooper comes in to
score and it's a five-nothing marlins
lead
this was a one-two pitch that he
launched for a 420-foot home run
there's a bouncer behind the back at
third and pass boom down the line
another hit for cooper he's got himself
a double and dickerson will end up
coming all the way around to score it's
six nothing marlins so cooper's got a
double a triple and a home run in the
seventh inning tonight welcome back six
nothing marlins heading to the last of
the ninth inning zach pop into the ball
game the fourth pitcher tonight for the
marlins and this will be game number 13
for zach pop
his major league debut earlier this year
has been on a nice roll right now his
last eight games which covered 10 and a
third
have been scoreless just a couple of
walks and 11 strikeouts in that span
it's really starting to come together
for the young man
rafael marchand will pinch hit here
picture spotless due up swinging into
miss he's down on strikes for the first
out of the night that fastball's got
some serious movement to it in late and
when he throws that slider in there too
it's nasty so i think that if they're
able to maintain him on the roster all
year this is going to be a sneaky pickup
well
right now it doesn't feel like they're
having to work too hard to keep them on
this roster in all reality yeah
he's pitching well enough to be a part
of this bullpen
here's brad miller with one out and
nobody on base
there's called strike three a slider up
it was a strike miller hates the call
he's about to get thrown out of this
game
right in the face of dan iasonia and
he's been ejected that pitcher was a
strike yeah caught the top edge and i'm
not talking about nicking that top edge
it's that's a ball that got there but
that one that got miller thrown in the
game was a strike and miller being
guided back to the dugout by his manager
joe girardi
was still right until he got to the top
step of the dugout having some words for
iasonia alec baum is the last hope for
the fills nobody on two outs last of the
ninth marlin six phillies nothing
swinging at a miss he struck him out
with the slider and the marlins combined
on a three-hit shutout to win this ball
game and take the series in philadelphia